ordre du jour appelle le débat sur le
thème les collectivités territoriales et
le financement des lieux de culte
demande de la délégation sénatoriale aux
collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation
la parole est à monsieur hervé maurey
rapporteur de cette délégation
sénatoriale
vous avez la parole
sa collègue madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues dans
quelques mois nous célébrerons les 110
ans de la loi de séparation de l'église
et de l'état et la question qu'on peut
se poser c'est de savoir si près de 110
ans après l'élaboration de cette loi
celle ci est toujours adaptée à notre
société
c'est la question qu'a voulu se poser la
délégation collectivités territoriales
et à la décentralisation alors présidée
par jacqueline gourault qui m'a confié
le rapport que j'ai l'honneur de
présenter aujourd'hui ce rapport nous
sembler justifié parce que effectivement
depuis 2000 depuis 1905 la société a
beaucoup changé
la religion dominante de l'époque la
religion catholique a connu une baisse
importante de sa pratique de nouvelles
religions sont apparus bien sûr l'islam
mais aussi d'autres religions comme le
mouvement évangélique et donc pour mener
à bien ces travaux
j'ai souhaité rencontrer l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés les représentants des
services de l'état les élus des
représentants des juridictions
administratives des associations des
universitaires et bien sûr l'ensemble
des représentants des religions
aucune religion n'a été oublié ce
travail nous avons souhaité également
l'enrichir d'une double dimension une
dimension internationale grâce à une
étude de la législation comparée dans un
certain nombre de pays l'allemagne
l'espagne l'italie le royaume-uni mais
surtout en associant à cette réflexion
les élus de terrain et en lançant une
consultation qui a été adressée a dit me
lemaire consultation à laquelle 3000
d'entre eux ont répondu et ses réponses
ont été complétés par des entretiens
directs
individualisé avec un certain nombre
d'élus il ressort de ces travaux bien
sûr que les élus locaux sont en ce
domaine comme dans bien d'autres en
première ligne face aux demandes
croissantes de financement
je voudrais rappeler que nos communes
abritent 45me l'église catholique
quatre mille lieux de culte protestant
420 synagogue 150 églises catholiques
2450 mosquée et 380 lieux de culte
bouddhistes
les communes ont directement la charge
de l'entretien des églises qui pèse de
manière importante dans leur budget
surtout à une époque où les dotations
sont en forte baisse mais il faut bien
reconnaître que les travaux sur les
églises en général recueille un certain
consensus même un consensus certains
parce que les églises dans les communes
et notamment des plus petites d'entre
elles constituent souvent le seul
élément est le seul élément patrimonial
pour les autres cultes
la question qui se pose est davantage
celle de la construction de nouveaux
édifices
alors quel est le cadre juridique posé
par la loi de 1905
le cadre juridique posé par la loi de
1905 est simple c'est l'interdiction
faite aux collectivités territoriales de
financer la construction l'acquisition
ou le fonctionnement d'édifices cultuels
c'est le principe un principe qui
comporte un certain nombre d'exceptions
première exception la législation
adoptée en 1907 et 1908 à transférer la
propriété des églises catholiques aux
communes puisque l'église catholique a
refusé de se constituer en association
cultuelle comme le prévoyait la loi de
1905 et donc dès lors que ces églises
appartiennent maintenant aux communes
elles sont entretenues comme l'ensemble
des biens communaux par ces communes il
existe aussi un régime dérogatoire sur
les territoires d'alsace et de moselle
qui à l'époque ne faisait pas partie de
la république et il faut non que sous
régime de concordat il existe aussi des
exceptions sur un certain nombre de
territoires d'outre-mer et puis des
dérogations ont été ajoutés plus
récemment par la législation
je pense à la possibilité de garantir
les emprunts qu'ils sont souscrits par
les associations cultuelles pour
l'édification de lieux
dans les agglomérations en développement
et par ailleurs la possibilité de
recourir à un bail emphytéotique pour
permettre la construction de ces lieux a
ses exceptions s'ajoute une
jurisprudence très favorable au
financement
je dis souvent que la loi de 1905 ne
ressemble plus à ce qu'elle était en
parce que la jurisprudence l'a
interprété de manière très très
favorable l'aller la jurisprudence a
notamment reconnu la possibilité de
mettre à disposition des locaux
communaux pour les activités cultuelles
dès lors que cette mise à disposition
s'effectue de manière provisoire et
l'inde exclusive et puis surtout la
jurisprudence a introduit une
distinction entre le cultuel et le
culturel et c'est ainsi qu' aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on construit un bâtiment pour une
pour un culte s'il y a dans ce bâtiment
une partie qui est cultuel et une partie
qui est culturel et c'est le cas en ce
moment à paris sur sa vente de projets
que ce soit pour l'église islamique ou
pour la religion juive
et bien dès lors qu'il y à une partie
culturelle il y a la possibilité que
cette partie là soient subventionnés par
la collectivité alors à l'issue de nos
auditions nous sommes parvenus à la
conclusion que nous ne pouvions pas
modifier la loi de 1905 qui constitue un
fondement tout à fait essentiel de la
république de notre vivre ensemble à une
loi qui incarne à elle seule la laïcité
française mais tout en préservant la loi
de 1905 nous avons retenu à proposer des
améliorations pour faciliter la vie des
élus et les collectivités nous
recommandations ont été adoptées par
l'unanimité de la délégation de la
délégation sont conformes à la tradition
sénatoriales puisqu'elles sont
pragmatiques et raisonnable mais en même
temps je le pense nécessaire et efficace
elle s'articule autour de trois axes
premier axe améliorer l'information des
élus deuxième axe faciliter le dialogue
entre les religions et les collectivités
territoriales et troisième axe renforcer
le contrôle sur le financement des lieux
de culte
améliorer l'information des élus est
nécessaire puisque comme je l'indiquais
la jurisprudence a considérablement fait
évoluer la loi de 1905 et on sait bien
que la jurisprudence n'est pas toujours
accessible pour l'ensemble des élus et
nous sommes même interrogé sur le fait
de savoir s'il fallait pas codifié la
jurisprudence
nous n'avons pas retenu cette
proposition parce que la jurisprudence a
le mérite d'offrir plus de souplesse qu
une codification mais nous pensons qu'il
faut un certain nombre de circulaire
prise par le ministre concerné je pense
notamment à la possibilité accordée aux
communes de financer des réparations
d'édifices cultuels appartenant à des
associations
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça n'est pas très
clair et ça n'est pas très clair non
plus la question de la mise à
disposition de locaux au bénéfice
d'associations cultuelles très souvent
les mères reçoivent des demandes de deux
lieux de mise à disposition de lieux par
des associations cultuelles et les
maires ne savent pas s'ils doivent
refuser s'ils peuvent refuser s'ils
peuvent accepter s'ils doivent accepter
et donc il y a vraiment besoin de
clarification deuxième axe de
recommandations faciliter les rapports
entre les communautés religieuses les
pouvoirs publics
je disais tout à l'heure que la garantie
d'emprunt est possible pour la
construction d'édifices cultuels
seulement dans les communes en voie de
développement cette notion nous semble
aujourd'hui dépassé nous semble que la
garantie d'emprunt pourraient devraient
être accordés dans tous les cas nous
proposons également que dans le cadre de
baux emphytéotiques il y ait la
possibilité de prévoir une clause de
rachat aux termes du bail
pourquoi parce que très souvent les baux
emphytéotiques peuvent se transformer en
bombe à retardement
je prendrai l'exemple de la ville de
paris qui dit si les années 2020-2030 va
récupérer une trentaine d'églises
ce qui impliquera un entretien d'environ
1 m dos de pardon de plusieurs millions
d'euros
et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui pour les
églises catholiques se passera dans
quelques années dans des villes comme
marseille ou montreuil pour les mosquées
puisque dans ces villes des baux
emphytéotiques ont été accordées pour
construire des mosquées
donc nous proposons c'est que cette
option d'achat nous proposons également
la possibilité
et pour les mères de déterminer dans
leur pays à l'ue les secteurs sur
lesquels peuvent être construits des
lieux de culte parce qu'aujourd'hui les
élus n'ont aucune marge de manoeuvre
quant à la détermination des territoire
de leur commune des parties du
territoire d'or commune sur lequel des
lieux de culte peuvent être construits
ou non troisième axe nous avons souhaité
renforcer la transparence sur le
financement des lieux de culte
nous pensons qu'il faudrait tout d'abord
qu'un décret pour le coup c'est un
décret sur ce point que nous
recommandons un décret en conseil d'état
précise précise ce qui relève du cultuel
du culturel parce que très souvent nous
sommes face à une situation assez flou
qui est source de confusion pour ne pas
dire hypocrisie et puis enfin il nous
semble nécessaire d'assurer un certain
contrôle du financement des lieux de
culte au niveau local parce
qu'aujourd'hui lorsqu'un lorsqu un lieu
de culte construit on ne sait absolument
pas comment il est financé et c'est
tellement vrai que traquent fin a dû
dans certains cas s'interroger sur
certaines sources de financement qui
apparaissait pour la construction
notamment deux mosquées donc nous
recommandons que dans le cadre de la
construction d'un édifice cultuel les
maîtres d'ouvragé présente un plan de
financement certifiés par un commissaire
aux comptes
voilà madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la
contribution de votre délégation sur ce
sujet l'actualité de l'année 2015
renforce mais malheureusement l'acuité
de nos travaux et nos propositions qui
je vous le rappelle ont été approuvés à
l'unanimité
une unanimité qui témoigne du sens des
responsabilités de notre assemblée
dans son rapport remis le 15 avril
dernier au présent de la république sur
la nation française
le président larcher relevé avec
justesse que les religions je le site
constitue un fait social et demeure une
donnée vivante de notre société qu'il
faut aborder sans rejet et sans crainte
c'est dans cet esprit que s'inscrit ce
débat c'est dans cet esprit que je
déposerait une proposition de loi à
l'issue de nos travaux en prenant en
compte les débats que nous aurons cet
après midi je vous remercie
merci chers collègues dans la suite du
débat la parole est à monsieur yvon
collin pour six minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
cent dix ans après la promulgation de la
loi de séparation des églises et de
l'état
un tournant historique où les radicaux
et notre groupe à l'époque ici-même
n'ont pas joué à main ce rôle force est
de constater que notre société a
profondément changé en particulier dans
sa sociologie et dans sa composition
religieuse s'il ne nous appartient pas
de juger de l'émergence de certaines
croyances unis dans certain renouveau du
sentiment de la pratique religieuse qui
relève de la sphère privée il est en
revanche de notre responsabilité en tant
que représentant des territoires et plus
encore de la nation d'être plus que
jamais vigilants face aux dérives de
toutes sortes
que peuvent les accompagner dans ce
contexte la loi de 1905 défini un cadre
qui a fait ses preuves depuis plus d'un
siècle et qu'il faut préserver
disons le très clairement pour nous il
n'est pas question de toucher à cette
loi fondatrice aussi sur ce point nous
partageons pleinement les
recommandations du rapport d'information
le respect strict du principe de laïcité
dans la sphère publique est notre
meilleure assurance contre toutes les
dérives religieuses ou sectaires la loi
de séparation des églises et de l'état
traduit ce principe par le refus du
subventionnement des cultes
c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons que
déplorer le relâchement de la vigilance
depuis des années de la part des
autorités ou des élus voire parfois la
complaisance à l'égard de certaines
revendications identitaires
ce qui pour suivre des intérêts
électoraux détriment de l'intérêt
général n'aboutiront qu'à mines et la
cohésion nationale et l'ordre
républicain renforcer le communautarisme
et donc aggraver les tensions entre les
membres de la communauté nationale
bien évidemment nous soutenons fermement
la volonté exprimée par la délégation
sénatoriale d'apporter davantage de
transparence au financement des lieux de
culte
il faut définir explicitement par la
voix d'un décret en conseil d'état
les types de dépenses relevant du
cultuel et du culturel probablement
faut-il rendre obligatoire
artix fication par un commissaire aux
comptes des plans de financement de la
construction d'édifices cultuels plus
certainement
il faut une meilleure information des
élus car trop souvent les mères n'ont
pas une parfaite connaissance des règles
en vigueur sur les dépenses et les aides
autorisées clarifiée c'est le maître mot
il n'est pas acceptable dans une
république laïque de maintenir une
quelconque ambiguïté sur les pratiques
de financement des lieux de culte
le rapport aborde les enjeux spécifiques
de la religion musulmane
en l'espèce notre groupe adopte une
position résolument laïque nous ne
distinguons aucune religion et par
conséquent l'acquisition de terrains la
mise à disposition de locaux ou la
construction de mosquées dans des
communes concernées doit respecter les
règles énoncées dans la loi de 1905 et
ne saurait y avoir ni contournement ni
régime des grottes dérogatoire sans cela
on risque d'ouvrir une boîte de pandore
outre que rien ne justifie en principe
accordé des financements occultes
musulmans à raison de ses difficultés
financières exposerait la puissance
publique aux revendications notre culte
qui se sentiraient ainsi fondé à
réclamer aussi des moyennes en effet
pourquoi refuser alain ce que l'on
aurait accordé à l'autre ces chers
collègues qu une pente dangereuse qui
nous faut garder le suivre c'est
pourquoi il nous faut un principe simple
une règle claire qu'ils soient les mêmes
pour tous en outre même si le rapport
montre que le financement des lieux de
culte musulmans par des états étrangers
est minoritaire ce qui est de nature
d'ailleurs à nous rassurer nous devons
rester vigilants afin d'empêcher la
promotion sur le territoire national de
conception rigoriste rigoriste des
religions par des acteurs étrangers
il n'est pas c'est le laisser tel ou tel
état ou une organisation à intervenir
dans le financement des lieux de culte
où que ce soit sur le territoire
national comme cela était d'ailleurs mis
en évidence par les équipes de tracfin
il s'agit d'un jeu de souveraineté et de
cohésion nationale pourquoi ne pas être
ferme jusqu'au bout et interdire
purement et simplement le financement
étranger à l'instar de ce qui se fait
déjà s'échappe certains voisins
européens sur d'autres points du rapport
nous exprimant des réserves sont opposés
à certaines propositions qui risque de
permettre des subventionnements déguisé
contraire à la foi à l'esprit mais aussi
à la lettre de la loi de 1905
il en va ainsi de la proposition de
création d'une option d'achat au profit
d'associations religieuses dans le cadre
de baux emphytéotiques conclu par les
communes avec ces dernières
de même tous les projets de financement
partiels fondés sur la distinction très
discutable entre activités cultuelles et
activités culturelles ne nous semble pas
acceptable
rappelons le la laïcité tout sauf une
attente envers des citoyennes c'est le
contre et c'est au contraire un synonyme
de liberté est indispensable outil du
vivre ensemble dans une société
multiconfessionnelle en deux mots un
bien commun qui nous faut à tout prix
préserver qu'il nous faut à tout prix
promouvoir c'est pourquoi notre groupe
reste fermement attaché à la loi de 1905
et à la séparation du politique et du
religieux elle aussi notre position sur
les propositions du rapport de notre
collègue hervé morin découle de ce
principe simple mais ô combien
républicain la loi de 1905 toute la loi
de 1905
rien que la loi de 1905 je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
d'autant plus que le temps est
parfaitement respectée je vous félicite
la parole est à monsieur stéphane ravier
pour 3 minutes
c
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mes chers collègues alors que bien des
collectivités se plaignent de la baisse
de leurs dotations certaines continuent
à utiliser des ressources publiques
devenues rares pourtant pour financer
les lieux de culte au mépris de la loi
sur ce sujet complexe ne nous trompons
pas de débat et sachons hiérarchiser les
gens les enjeux la question principale
du financement des lieux de culte par
l'école les collectivités locales c'est
la pressions communautaristes exercée
aujourd'hui sur nombre d'élus et la
complaisance électoraliste de certains
d'entre eux qui leur fait utilisé jusqu
aux limites de la légalité et nombreuses
possibilités offertes par la loi
française
je pense notamment au subventionnement
de projets dits mixtes à la fois
cultuelles et culturelles qui font tout
pour promouvoir des identités étrangères
empêchant par là même l'accès à notre
modèle républicain d'assimilation et
même d'intégration voulons nous que
l'argent du contribuable français
servent à financer les lieux culturaux
cultuelle qui sont parfois des lieux de
radicalisation pouvant mener jusqu au
djihadisme et qui sont bien souvent des
vecteurs d'influencé étrangères
votre rapport lui-même reconnaît la
fragmentation communautaire dû aux liens
persistants avec le pays d'origine
je pourrais vous parler longtemps du
triste et ô combien emblématique
feuilleton de la grande mosquée avortée
de marseille avorté car n'était qu'un
vaste champ de bataille et des
influences entre pays étrangers bataille
relayer et menées par des acteurs locaux
dont une était conseillère régionale
socialiste de surcroît un projet
pourtant voulu soutenu et défendu par le
premier magistrat de la ville comme
étant une vitrine de l'islam de france
d'autant que ce n'est pas tout de
construire
ensuite il faut entretenir
rt dans un article en ligne du 6 avril
dernier sur l'islam en france prenez
l'exemple de marseille où monsieur
abderrahmane ghoul le vice président du
conseil régional du culte musulman de
provence alpes côte d'azur d'éclat sur
les 60 salles qui existent seuls trois
sont aux normes
et certaines sont mêmes frappés par des
ordres de fermeture
dieu merci la municipalité je cite je
cite je cite je cite toujours dieu merci
la municipalité et les autorités ferment
un peu les yeux mais ça ne peut pas
durer et monsieur ghoul depuis de
poursuivre le financement des mosquées
pose lui aussi problème
il y a des ressources la viande halal
par exemple les grandes boucheries paie
une taxe avec elle on peut avancer de
grands projets c'est donc une autre
grande question qui est posée celle du
financement involontaire c'est à dire
non souhaitée des mosquées en effet
l'étiquetage halal n'est pas généraliser
et que donc la plupart d'entre nous
achetons de la viande halal sans le
savoir et finances ont donc
potentiellement la construction de
mosquées sans le savoir et sans
forcément le vouloir
là encore marine le pen est la seule à
avoir eu le courage de mettre les pieds
dans le plat il ya déjà plusieurs années
pour conclure et pour conclure dernier
point le financement étranger des lieux
de culte votre rapport minimise le
phénomène en se focalisant sur le film
le financement officielle par les états
qu'il nous faut absolument interdire
il ya une zone grise dont on devine à
l'ampleur quand on lit que les maires
réclament une main un meilleur contrôle
des flux financiers participants la
construction d'ouvragés cultuelle sur le
terrain il est souvent très difficile et
je conclus sur le terrain il est souvent
très difficile d'identifier précisément
l'origine des fonds des porteurs de
projets notamment lorsqu'il s'agit
d'espèces lan koné tonnes notamment
l'importance des forces l'étranger at
river qui peuvent parvenir jusqu'en
france par divers canaux notamment
pseudo caritatif l'enjeu d'aujourd'hui
n'est donc pas seulement la laïcité mais
la souveraineté de notre pays l'on ne
pourra pas défendre l'une qu'en
défendant l'autre
alors la parole est désormais à madame
françoise gatel pour 8 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues la loi de 1905 incitant la
séparation de l'église et de l'état a
instauré une laïcité à la française dont
les contours variable faute de véritable
définition constitutionnel ont fortement
évolué elle repose sur une vanité
antagonistes entre la sphère privée où
la liberté de chacun prévost et la
sphère publique ou la neutralité
religieuse prévost ainsi l'état et les
collectivités locales ne doivent ni
intervenir dans les affaires religieuses
ni financer des besoins liés aux
religions mais la situation n'est pas
toujours si simple et confronte les
maires à des problématiques complexes
en ce sens je tiens à souligner
l'intérêt remarquable de rapports
réalisés par notre collègue hervé maurey
qui amène un travail approfondi et
nuancé sur cette question du financement
des lieux de culte qui préoccupe les
élus travail initié sous la présidence
de madame jacqueline gourault mes chers
collègues vous le savez le principe est
celui de l'interdiction de toute aide
directe ou indirecte occulte les
subventions des collectivités locales
aux associations cultuelles ou destiné
aux lieux de culte sont donc prohibé
néanmoins nos communes le plus souvent
propriétaires de lieux de culte
construits avant 1905 peuvent les
entretenir et les réparer sans pour
autant pouvoir y faire des dépenses
qu'elle souhaiterait sauf si un intérêt
public local et reconnue dans le respect
de certaines conditions
en effet le conseil d'état estime que si
l'initiative locale répond à un besoin
de la population la dépense est alors
légales pour autant la commune devra
veiller à la mixité des bénéficiaires de
l'équipement financé selon un principe
d'intérêt général faire la part des
choses et donc loin d'être toujours aisé
difficulté à laquelle vient s'ajouter la
question du financement ce patrimoine
communal vous l'avez rappelé qui doit
être entretenue pèse très lourd dans les
budgets des communes
dès lors comment aider à trouver comment
aider les mains à trouver des
financements
en premier lieu vous l'avez également
dit une meilleure information des élus
sur les dispositifs existants s'impose
la problématique diffèrent selon que
l'église soit classée au nom si les
églises sont classées elles sont
éligibles aux aides de la braque ce
n'est pas le cas des églises non classé
qui sont largement majoritaires
les communes se trouvent alors dans
l'impossibilité d'entretenir un
patrimoine reçu en héritage
dans mon département d'ille et vilaine
où plusieurs communes sont confrontées à
de réelles difficultés nous avons pu
affecter de la detr à des travaux
relative à la mise en sécurité de ces
édifices et aux seuls travaux de mise en
sécurité
n'est ce pas là une idée à reprendre au
niveau national si l'entretien des
églises pose un certain nombre de
problèmes les demandes de construction
de nouveaux lieux de culte prospère en
effet le paysage religieux français a
beaucoup évolué depuis plusieurs
décennies confrontant de plus en plus
les mères à ce type de demande
ils se retrouvent souvent très seul sur
un sujet parfois mal perçus par la
population face à cette situation
complexe
les mères sont souvent contraints dans
un souci de pragmatisme d'user d'outils
ichi de l'évolution de la jurisprudence
ainsi le bail emphytéotique représente
un dispositif efficace pour construire
un édifice cultuel toutefois l'option
d'achat de l'édifice
à l'issue de l'échéance par les
associations cultuelles nécessite d'être
précisé pour apporter les garanties
juridiques nécessaires aux communes
comment s'assurer à la signature d'un
bail emphytéotique le bien se racheter à
son échéance et par qui qu'arrive-t-il
si le bâtiment est abandonné pendant la
durée du bail
comment éviter que le bâtiment ne
revienne à la charge de la commune par
ailleurs certaines communes peuvent
accorder une garantie d'emprunt au
groupement culturel afin de faciliter
l'obtention d'un prêt bancaire
le rapport de notre éminent collègue
propose un élargissement l'ensemble du
territoire
si cette idée est excellente pour autant
ce dispositif peut présenter des risques
financiers non négligeables pour les
communes qu'il convient de sécuriser
enfin le droit de l'urbanisme peut
représenter un outil extrêmement
pertinent pour réserver un emplacement
aux protégés dans le plus un édifice
cultuel pouvant avoir également une
vocation culturelle
mais la recommandation du rapporteur
visant à mieux maîtriser les lieux
d'implantation en précisant clairement
les emplacements de ces édifices dans le
pays et lui permettrait effectivement à
la fois de sécuriser les maires et
surtout d'initier un débat très en amont
et plus apaisée avec les administrés la
tendance à adosser un projet cultuelle
un projet culturel est évidemment
ambivalente est sujet à interprétation
et les distinctions jury présidentielle
sont parfois équivoques
c'est cette zone un peu trouble permet
au maire ou à l'état parfois de déroger
à la loi de 1905 en participant
indirectement au financement de lieux de
culte aussi une explicitation très
officielle de ce qui peut relever du
cultuel et du culturel semble
indispensable pour conforter et
sécuriser les élus mais également éviter
les dérives
autre sujet important qui a été aussi
évoquée c'est l'opacité qui règne autour
du financement de certains lieux de
culte
nous savons tous notamment que des
mosquées sont construits grâce au
concours financier de pays étrangers
ces apports pouvant représenter jusqu'à
50% du financement
un état de fait qui interroge un état
républicain et pose la question de la
souveraineté de l' influence de la
situation géopolitique internationale
sur le fait religieux
les élus monsieur le rapporteur
effectivement réclament un meilleur
contrôle des flux financiers de
l'origine de ces fonds on le voit les
élus locaux sont sans cesse sur le fil
du rasoir
jouant un numéro d'équilibriste
insécurisés la jurisprudence a évolué à
supplie la loi de 1905
en apportant des réponses nouvelles qui
concilie laïcité réalité du terrain pour
autant il paraît incontournable de
clarifier certains outils pour sécuriser
les maires sur un plan juridique mais
aussi sur un plan financier et leur
permettent d'affronter plus sereinement
cette problématique
notre groupe udc est très attaché à
l'esprit de la loi de 1905 et émettra
donc un avis favorable aux propositions
de notre rapporteur je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur françois grosdidier
merci madame la présidente madame le
ministre chers collègues notre excellent
collègue hervé morin mort et pardon
hervé maurey décrit de façon juste les
conditions de l'exercice des cultes en
france et le rôle qu'ils jouent les
communes
je partage pleinement ses analyses et
quasiment toutes ses conclusions mais je
serais allé plus loin au risque de
briser un tabou au moment le plus
défavorable quand une part grandissante
de l'opinion ne résonne plus mais réagit
de façon épidermique sur la question je
crois qu'il faut changer les modalités
pratiques de la loi 1905 pour rester
conforme aux principes de la loi de 1905
auquel je suis aussi attachés qu'ils
vont colin ces principes sont plus
actuel et pertinent que jamais et ils
sont pour moins tangibles dans la
république
mais certaines des modalités sont datés
obsolète que dit la loi de 1905 pas
d'argent pour les cultes sauf pour
l'entretien des deux culte construits
avant 1905 église catholique temple
protestant synagogue mais bien sûr pas
églises évangéliques et encore moins
mosquée dans sa grande sagesse
le législateur keane la sagesse n'est
pas la divination
le législateur ne pouvait pas anticiper
l'émergence des églises évangéliques
encore moins celle de l'islam devenu
deuxième religion de france
il en résulte une inégalité de fait une
inégalité criante
la société française a de surcroît
concentrer les musulmans dans certains
quartiers dans certaines villes dans la
mienne
ils représentent la moitié de la
population élu maire en 2001 mes
administrés musulmans exercer leur culte
dans une salle trop petite
un ancien commerce racheté par
souscription il priait serrés comme des
sardines et ils priaient dans la rue
c'était indigne pour eux est
insupportable pour les riverains
que peut faire un maire devant une telle
situation aujourd'hui ou bien laisser
faire et accepter à l'intérieur la
violation de la réglementation sur les
rp et à l'extérieur les entraves à la
circulation et des troubles à l'ordre
public ou bien interdire l'exercice du
culte et violine libertés fondamentales
à valeur constitutionnelle
ou bien alors offrir un local communal
et contrevenir à la loi de 1905
j'ai choisi la troisième option qui me
paraissait la seule juge
et j'ai même construit seul maire de
france je crois avoir construit une
mosquée sur fonds publics
j'ai pu le faire légalement dans ma
commune parce que je suis élu en moselle
départements concordataires je suis
désolé parce que je suis un militant des
valeurs portées par le web 1905 de la
laïcité
je refuse tout dogmatisme je suis un
militant de la liberté absolue de
conscience de l'égalité de la fraternité
qui transcende les croyances et les
appartenances
mais comment au nom de la loi de 1905
expliquer à nos concitoyens musulmans
que parce qu'il n'était pas là en 1905
ils n'auront jamais les mêmes droits que
les pratiquants de notre des autres
religions dans notre république
j'entends dire que le financement du
culte est une affaire privée et que des
pratiquants n'ont qu'à financer leurs
lieux de culte
c'est une tartufferie la générosité des
pratiquants musulmans comme ceux de
celle de tous les pratiquants est réelle
mais ils n'appartiennent pas aux
catégories socioprofessionnelles les
plus aisés et n'auront jamais le moyen
de financer des rp conforme la
réglementation d'une capacité suffisante
le financement privé par les pratiquants
en france n'est pas réaliste
le seul financement privé possible est
suffisant est un financement étranger et
la république est schizophrène
lorsqu'elle demande à juste titre à ses
citoyens musulmans d'édifier un islam de
france et non pas en france et que dans
le même temps elle les invite à chercher
le financement des mosquées dans les
pays du golfe et le financement des
imams dans les pays du maghreb et la
fondation censé recueillir contrôle et
distribuer les dons n'a donné aucun
résultat dix ans après de l'aveu même du
ministre d'intérieur
la vérité c'est que beaucoup de maires
sont contraints de contourner la loi en
mettant à disposition des pratiquants
des édifices officiellement culturel et
officieusement cultuelle l'état ferme
les yeux
sauf quand le juge administratif est
saisi l'état a lui même utilisé cet
artifice pour financer la cathédrale
d'evry bien après 1905
les maires sont obligés de s'affranchir
de la lettre de la loi
pour rester conforme à son esprit la
laïcité c'est la neutralité de l'état à
l'égard des religions c'est l'égalité de
tous devant la loi 2
les citoyens sans distinction d'origine
de race ou de religion
c'est aussi la laïcité la liberté de
culte
aujourd'hui certains d'extrême droite
mais je regrette aussi celle dans le
camp des républicains de droite comme de
gauche
certains suggère d'interdire à la fois
le financement public et le financement
étranger
cela reviendrait à interdire de fait
l'exercice du culte musulman en france
je sais que nous sommes dans une époque
dominée par la peur et la confusion que
la peur de l'islam est nourri par
l'actualité internationale que la haine
de l'autre et renforcé par la crise
économique et sociale et le débat public
confond à tort surtout lorsqu'il s'agit
les musulmans communautarisme est simple
pratique du culte ou expressions de la
foi religieuse
il n'en demeure pas moins que certains
musulmans pas nécessairement terroristes
doivent parfois être rappelés à l'ordre
républicain
la république est en droit d'exiger de
leur part un effort d'intégration mais
la république n'est pas crédible quand
elle pose des règles nouvelles en
donnant le sentiment de deux poids deux
mesures elle n'est pas crédible
lorsqu en exigeant le respect des mêmes
devoirs elle refuse les mêmes droits on
ne peut pas au nom de l'histoire
justifié pour l'éternité
l'inégalité de traitement dans
l'exercice d'un droit fondamental
la république doit traiter tous ses
citoyens de la même façon elle n'en sera
que mieux fondées à imposer à tous les
mêmes obligations
il faudrait avoir cette audace l'islam
de france vit dans une grande misère
immobilière et intellectuelle à défaut
de formation des imams sur la question
immobilière c'est vrai il faudrait
doubler le nombre de mosquées c'est un
fait objectif
certainement pas en deux ans pour
attraper 70 ans de retard et on peut pas
demander à l'état d'y contribuer en
pleine crise des finances publiques si
l'état déjà continue à soutenir les
communes pour l'entretien des églises et
du pathé mailly ce temps ce serait bien
mais simplement qu'on laisse la liberté
aux maires de pouvoir financer des de
tulle dès lors qu'il ya carence de
l'offre privée que ça répond aux besoins
d'une partie substantielle de la
population aujourd'hui un maire peut
ouvrir un débit de boisson s'il ya
carence de l'offre privée et ne peut pas
officiellement illégalement financé un
lieu de culte il ne s'agirait en aucun
cas de créer une obligation pour
la commune mais de donner une liberté à
la commune parce que la commune est la
cellule de base de la république
la commune et le régulateur social par
excellence
même si elle est malmenée dans tous les
textes législatifs que nous présente et
sur ces questions qui hystérise notre
société la commune et le cadre de la
connaissance mutuelle de la place faite
à chacun du respect des règles communes
la société devient celle de tous les
excès la commune reste le lieu d
équilibre la société exacerbe les
antagonistes la commune rapproche les
individus de toute façon condamnée à
vivre ensemble
la république doit davantage s'appuyer
sur les communes pour faire revivre et
partager ses valeurs au quotidien et je
crois profondément que le sénat devrait
demande à la république d'avoir l'audace
de faire confiance au maire merci chers
collègues
la parole est à monsieur rené
vandierendonck pour 14 minutes
oui
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur hervé maurey mes
chers collègues le 19 décembre 2002
toutes les formations politiques qui
composent le conseil municipal de
roubaix à l'exception notable du front
national ont approuvé un schéma
directeur de la ville sur les lieux de
culte
cette délibération cadre a été
l'aboutissement d'un dialogue importants
et nourris entre les pouvoirs publics et
les associations cultuelles ou non en
effet il était important dans le respect
de la laïcité de prendre acte de
l'existence de nouvelles religions dans
une ville de tissage et de métissage
partant de ce constat il est essentiel
que chaque roubaisien puissent pratiquer
le culte qui souhaitent et ce dans de
bonnes et digne conditions c'est un des
principes forts du vivre ensemble
il est important de dire qu en tout
point ce schéma qui est toujours en
vigueur s'inscrivent strictement dans le
cadre aux républicains de la loi du 9
décembre 1905 relative à la séparation
des églises et de l'état et de son
interprétation par le conseil d'état qui
a rendu depuis cinq important arrêt
d'assembler le 19 juillet 2011 cher
monsieur moret et le groupe socialiste
se réjouit que vous ne remettez pas en
cause dans votre travail
les équilibres de la loi du 9 décembre
50 fin de 1905
il se réjouit également du fait que vous
soyez restés prudents sur les régimes
d'exception d'alsace moselle et
d'outre-mer alors vous proposés sous
forme de cette recommandation autour de
trois axes un certain nombre d'avancées
et on voit si vous voulez bien les
parcourir ensemble les deux premières
recommandations concernent l'information
des mères il s'agirait de
informé par voie de circulaire du
ministère de l'intérieur dans un souci
de sécurité accrue au plan juridique
d'une part vous l'avez dit sur les types
de dépenses qui peuvent être engagées au
titre de la conservation et de
l'entretien des édifices propriété de la
commune
d'autre part sur les possibilités dette
financière des communes pour des
réparations d'édifices cultuels
appartenant aux associations cultuelles
ainsi que les conditions de mise à
disposition de locaux au bénéfice de ces
dernières sur ces deux points
il faut rappeler que la circulaire du
ministère de l'intérieur du 29 juillet
2011 qui s'intitule d'ailleurs propriété
construction réparation et entretien
règles d'urbanisme et fiscalité c'est un
point relativement précis sur le champ
des possibles est donc allé au delà pose
nécessairement le problème de la nature
de la norme employés je préfère une
circulaire interprétative qui concerne
la souplesse de l'interprétation de la
jurisprudence à un texte qui viendraient
la figer concernant l'amélioration du
dialogue collectivités et associations
cultuelles pour permettre l'implantation
de nouveaux lieux de culte
votre rapport monsieur propose trois
autres recommandations la prob la
première propose d'étendre le dispositif
des garanties d'emprunt pour la
construction d'édifices cultuels à
l'ensemble du territoire
cette proposition c'est vrai
impliquerait de modifier la loi et
notamment les articles de 1252 4t 3231 5
du code général des collectivités
territoriales
ceci étant elle mérite d'être posée
cette question et elle mérite de faire
l'objet d'une investigation
complémentaire je fais observer que le
conseil d'état dans la philosophie des
arts est d'assembler qui l'a rendu en
juillet 2011 demandé que même pour
éviter le
risque de subventions déguisées demander
quand même que la garantie d'emprunt
soit effectué dans l'intérêt général et
je me demande s'il faut pas travailler
davantage cette question mais il ya une
piste
la deuxième recommandation concerne les
baux emphytéotiques administratifs
alors je vois bien votre inspiration
vous vous dites mais quand même ce
serait s'il ya une option d'achat donné
à l'association cultuelle à la fin du
bail
ça montre une volonté de pérenniser
l'affectation religieuse du lieu moi je
voudrais faire valoir un autre argument
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état permet que c'est bon
emphytéotique soit sur des durées
longues d'abord éventuellement
reconductible et qu'en plus à des
conditions assez modique de prix parce
que le conseil d'état estime que la
contrepartie est précisément le retour
dans le patrimoine de la collectivité
publique
au terme du bail là aussi ça mérite une
investigation complémentaire pour éviter
le rif que de subventionnement déguisés
et donc je suis prudent sur la
possibilité de rendre cet équilibre même
si je suis d'accord que c'est une
question qui peut et qui mérite d'être
posée la troisième recommandation vous
ne pardonnerait monsieur rapporteur mais
là je suis pas d'accord avec ce que j'ai
vu dans mon secteur de nord pas de
calais puisque vous disent on va
permettre dans le cadre des plus que les
zones susceptibles d'accueillir
l'implantation potentiel d'édifices
cultuels soir père et moi je fais
observer que quand je consulte les
représentants des cultes
cette proposition ne fait est loin de
faire l'unanimité
je fais observer également que le maire
qui ne veut pas d'un lieu de culte
on lui donnerait tout de suite
une possibilité en excluant ne sont plus
tous tonnages de ce type dans leur
n'exclure par contre mon quotidien à moi
dans le nord pas de calais c'est de voir
des mers présenté sur l'acquisition de
biens pour précisément éviter d
implantation de lieux de culte et donc
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
ce que disait ici
deux autres rapporteurs madame benbassa
et monsieur le ser dans un rapport
d'information qui avait trait à aux
discriminations et qui posait le
problème qu'on aura intérêt à se poser
en même temps c'est à dire comment
sanctionner le maire qui exercent
illégalement son droit de préemption
pour empêcher une liberté publique de
s'exercer donc alors vous dites ensuite
un décret en conseil d'état pour
solenniser en quelque sorte pour faire
la ligne de partage des eaux entre le
culturel et cultuel
là aussi je vois bien votre souci de
clarté
je pense que ça desservir et la cause
parce que je crois qu'il faut laisser la
souplesse à la jurisprudence sur ces
questions vous dites aussi la
traçabilité des financements moi
j'observe une chose j'ai essayé à
roubaix de dacie tmn donc d'accompagner
des associations cultuelles à choisir la
formule de la grande capacité juridique
dans la loi 1905
celle qui donne des exonérations
fiscales
mais celle qui assure la traçabilité des
sources de financement pas une pas une
association un gode pr temple protestant
mosquées associations cultuelles
catholique pas une association n'a
accepté
la formule en question alors monsieur
murray dit ah bah y'a qu'à penser à ce
moment là un contrôle de l'origine des
fonds par un commissaire aux comptes
je crains que ce contrôle dont je vois
bien encore une fois la finalité ne soit
pas possible dans l'état actuel de la
jurisprudence du conseil d'état
s'agissant de l'exercice d'une liberté
de culte
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre un débat
sur les collectivités territoriales est
le financement des lieux de culte
un débat qui fait suite au rapport du
sénateur centriste hervé maurey tout de
suite ses preuves par 3 avec comme
invité stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture et porte parole du
gouvernement